[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 la población
mundial alcanzó los 8.000 millones de
habitantes este 15 de noviembre del 2022
así lo dijo el informe de perspectivas
de la población mundial de Naciones
Unidas para el año 2080 seremos 10.400
millones de personas sin embargo la
población mundial está creciendo a su
ritmo anual más lento desde 1950 por
debajo del 1% en 2020 en un mundo que
trata de reconciliar el consumo de
recursos en un planeta cada vez más
poblado y la crisis de nacimientos el
enfoque de género puede ayudar
por eso la conversación sobre estos
retos de la fecundidad y de las
maternidades es con Natalia Escobar
paquiro ellas coordinadora de medición
del observatorio para la equidad de las
mujeres de la universidad icesi y de la
fundación WWE Natalia gracias a usted
por estar con nosotros
Ángela Muchas gracias por la invitación
vamos a empezar hoy por lo que muchas
personas se preguntan es correcto
Natalia decir que somos demasiados en el
planeta entre muchas razones por las que
las mujeres reconsideran asumir las
maternidades está esta creencia de que
no habría suficiente planeta para esos
posibles hijos que llegaran
bueno esa es una digamos una creencia
muy común entre las personas decir bueno
somos demasiados y tal vez lo que hay
que entrar a ver es cómo estamos
repartiendo los recursos no como nos
repartimos los recursos entre todos
porque hoy en día se producen
suficientes alimentos por ejemplo para
alimentar a toda la población mundial
cierto y hay las fuentes energéticas
para lograrlo sin embargo lo que vemos
es que
algunos países y particularmente algunas
personas se están quedando con la
concentración de esos recursos o de la
mayor parte de esos recursos y lo que
terminan pasando Pues bueno son estas
crisis de hambre crisis energéticas
digamos por la disputa de estos recursos
a que no Entonces no logran llegar a las
grandes mayorías pero
que hayamos llegado a los 8.000 millones
de personas implica que como humanidad
también hemos
sobrepasado digamos unos retos muy
importantes que nos plantea pues la vida
misma no la la naturaleza lo real Sí y
podríamos llegar a
sobrevivir siendo incluso más personas
pero sí hacemos cambios estructurales de
lo contrario Pues por supuesto Esto va a
seguir siendo insostenible en el tiempo
me gusta eso que dice de que podríamos
llegar a sobrevivir porque Bueno claro
Hay que darle las gracias por ejemplo a
que han disminuido las tasas de
mortalidad materna y mortalidad de
neonatos Y eso hace que también aumente
la esperanza de vida y que seamos más
cada vez en el planeta sin embargo ese
tema de que podríamos llegar a
sobrevivir si se hicieran cambios
estructurales nosotros queremos
abordarlo con un enfoque de Derechos
Humanos no entonces decir que somos
demasiados no sería pensar en Derechos
Humanos podría pensar en igualdad para
todas las personas sin embargo la
realidad es bien diferente y el declive
de nacimientos es una crisis más para la
que no estábamos preparados Hablamos de
una población envejecida que no puede
trabajar hijos únicos cuidando a padres
y a familiares mayores en generales es
como la perspectiva que se nos avecina
Por qué si podríamos sobrevivir están
bajando tanto las tasas de fertilidad y
esto está pasando en hombres y en
mujeres
bueno eso responde a las dinámicas de un
sistema económico que
nos dice que nuestras vidas son poco
valiosas cierto cuando una cuando una
pareja decide tener hijos seguramente
muchas parejas quisieran tener más hijos
de las que tienen No si nosotros vemos
por ejemplo Los Mega ricos del mundo
algunos de ellos deciden tener muchos
hijos porque claro es algo que se pueden
permitir Ah pero las grandes mayorías
pues no lo decían muchas mujeres por
ejemplo tienen su primer hijo y ven que
es una situación tan compleja de
conciliar frente al mercado de trabajo
el trabajo de cuidados el trabajo
doméstico que bueno restringen sus
posibilidades a un cliente a tener
masivos o las mujeres cada vez más
retrasan Las edades para tener los hijos
por eso es porque tenemos un sistema que
complejiza demasiado la vida de las
personas sí Entonces si nosotros vemos
en los países donde hay tecnologías de
reproducción mucho más avanzadas donde
las personas pueden elegir más la
cantidad y el momento del nacimiento de
los hijos pues efectivamente lo hacen no
y vemos cómo disminuyen esas tasas de
fertilidad ampliamente y en los países
donde no los hay es donde en este
momento tenemos unos crecimientos
poblacionales altísimos no en algunos
países de África en la India cierto
tenemos unos crecimientos altos por es
porque las personas tienen menos
posibilidades de acceder a las
tecnologías de información
sin embargo probablemente en los países
donde hay estas digamos estas
tecnologías pero al mismo tiempo
conviven con estas restricciones de un
sistema económico muy complejo pues lo
que termina pasando Es que las mujeres
particularmente son las que terminan
decidiendo tener más hijos por supuesto
algunos hombres también dicen Bueno yo
no no quiero tener hijos pero digamos
que la decisión no queda pues sobre
sobre sus manos sino que son las mujeres
las que finalmente deciden si quieren o
no y pues hoy en día las mujeres están
decidiendo tener masivos Y eso responde
a la complejidad de cuidar digamos el
momento histórico nos está diciendo
tenemos que poner en el centro a la vida
Al cuidado de la vida sí que ella
hagamos hayamos llegado a los 8.000
millones de personas no es una mala
noticia porque implica que con nuestras
tecnologías médicas logramos aumentar la
esperanza de vida pero al mismo tiempo
implica un reto muy grande sobre cómo
vamos a reproducir la vida en
condiciones de dignidad Porque
necesitamos que todas las personas
tengan una vida de ese digamos es como
el el fin de la humanidad en este
momento o al menos lo que nos deberíamos
estar pensando y lo que haríamos estar
discutiendo pues tenemos ahí varias
cosas por un lado está el tema de la
fertilidad no las razones hay que a las
que obedece como el ambiente de la lucha
misma contra el cambio climático que han
disminuido por ejemplo la calidad en el
esperma que producen los hombres o
tienen la capacidad de ser fértiles que
tenemos las mujeres y entre esas causas
aquí va mi siguiente Pregunta están la
Salud Mental que tiene mucha relación
antes de eso pues Claro está lo que
ustedes ya nos venía mencionando y es la
opción no ver cómo sería la perspectiva
de una maternidad Y a partir de ahí
elegir y en esto se basan muchísimo las
tareas de cuidado que deberían estar
repartidas diferente y probablemente las
mujeres
podríamos optar más libremente por las
maternidades ahora sobre la Salud Mental
como se relaciona esa Salud Mental eh
con la baja en la fertilidad tanto en
hombres como en mujeres
pues efectivamente está súper
relacionado no en este caso bueno en los
países digamos menos desarrollados o en
vías de desarrollo la categoría que
queramos usar lo que termina pasando Es
que muchas mujeres terminan teniendo
unas experiencias de maternidad
tempranas no No necesariamente por sus
propios hijos sino que te cuidan a sus
hermanitos cuidan a los niños del hogar
y entonces lo que termina pasando Es que
existen por ejemplo de ser madres porque
han tenido estas experiencias Pero
además digamos las personas Pues por
supuesto leen una crisis climática una
crisis global una crisis de desigualdad
de pobreza Pues que hace que se
restrinjan no cuando tus posibilidades
Pues de de que tu hijo hija sobrevivan
en el mundo
de manera indigna sean muy altas pues en
ese mismo día Pues tú dices Bueno pues
yo prefiero no no tener hijos o no tener
tantos hijos no Y por supuesto Esto está
supremamente ligado con la Salud Mental
en el sentido de que estas experiencias
terminan teniendo muchísimos efectos
Ahora cuando las personas tienen sus
primeras experiencias de maternidad y
paternidad
pues ven lo complejo Que es conciliar un
sistema económico cierto un mercado de
trabajo que te dice que vivas como si no
tuvieras familia cierto que lo más
importante es el trabajo y al mismo
tiempo
hacerte cargo de un niño o una niña
pequeña no Pero además con sistemas que
no son capaces de recoger
esas necesidades de las personas no por
ejemplo en América Latina No hemos
tenido estos regímenes de bienestar muy
fuertes sino que estamos muy supeditados
a sistemas familialistas es decir es la
familia en la que se tiene que hacer
cargo entonces si yo decido tener un
hijo una hija
pues es mi madre la que probablemente me
va a tener que ayudar No ya se va a ver
en la obligación de ayudarme a cuidar
ese niño o niña y eso pues Por supuesto
me va a dificultar mi es posibilidades
de por ejemplo tener otros hijos cierto
porque todo digamos toda mi economía y
toda Todo mi tiempo se va a ver volcado
a unas jornadas de trabajo súper
extenuantes no particularmente las
mujeres tienen dobles jornadas de
trabajo la jornada de trabajo que hacen
en el mercado de trabajo cierto y la
jornada de trabajo que luego Tienen que
llegar a ser al hogar el trabajo
doméstico de cuidados No remunerado pues
si tú tienes unas jornadas de trabajo
que si tú sumas las dos te da más de 10
horas más de 14 horas diarias de trabajo
pues por supuesto tu salud mental se va
a ver afectada y vas a tener unos
choques mentales muy fuertes no Entonces
ahí es donde vemos las mujeres sufriendo
muchísimos problemas o bueno muchísimos
problemas alrededor de la ansiedad
de sí digamos problemas en las que
incluso terminan
realizar o muchas mujeres que para poder
cumplir con estos estándares pues
terminan medicándose medicándose
automedicándose digamos con
metanfetaminas por ejemplo eso usamos
son fenómenos que empezamos a ver como
con mayor frecuencia sobre todo pues en
por ejemplo en los Estados Unidos hay
muchos más estudios no sobre por ejemplo
las madres tomando adegal para poder
soportar estas amplísimas jornadas de
trabajo entonces
si no logramos conciliar el sistema
económico es decir si no logramos sacar
del centro al mercado porque la
humanidad le ha dedicado muchísimo
tiempo y muchísimos recursos a mantener
tranquilos los mercados y al contrario
ponemos en el centro a la reproducción
de la vida y a los cuidados pues
definitivamente la población va a seguir
creciendo de estas maneras muy
desiguales no y estas formas desiguales
pues lo que terminan generando son unos
conflictos profundos no y tierra no
porque dice bien entonces guerra del
hambre guerra por el agua guerra por las
energías cierto y eso no va a Cesar sino
ponemos en el centro a la reproducción
de la vida Todo esto para apoyar la
teoría de que cerrar la brecha de género
podría contribuir a que se regularizaran
las poblaciones y sobre todo la calidad
de vida de las poblaciones y mire ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo pero yo le agradezco
muchísimo a Natalia por entregarnos este
análisis sobre lo que es la importancia
no solamente de la densidad poblacional
sino de una vida digna para nuestros
hijos y para nuestros nietos gracias a
ustedes y Gracias también a nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros en
ellas hoy nos vemos Próximamente también
en France 24 y en francés 24.com
[Música]